hello everyone i'm jesse i'm a
registered nurse and entrepreneur and i
make videos on minimalism and healthy
living
in this video i'm going to share with
you 50 things that i've declared from my
life
so that hopefully you can get some ideas
of things that you can declare in yours
to have a simpler happier life number
one
television yes you can survive without a
television
we got rid of our television because we
wanted to spend more time
together as a family and to have time
for our hobbies that we used to love
that were a bit more productive such as
my husband likes oil painting
i like to read we now have time for
those hobbies
and when somebody does come to visit us
the television is not the center focal
point we're not
just ignoring each other looking at a
screen we're actually talking we're
actually spending time together
number two netflix and hulu a lot of
these shows
we weren't even watching so they just
kind of were an extra expense at the end
of the month
and something else to think about having
to pay
number three and this one doesn't really
apply to me more so to my husband
but it was very difficult for him and it
was video games
number four is school awards and
certificates
matter of fact i actually took a
snapshot and downloaded my
bachelor's diploma and just got rid of
it completely
because it doesn't necessarily make me
proud
to say i have credentials what does
make me proud what does bring me joy is
to look at my family photos
to see the artwork that i have done or
that my husband has done
those things are more descriptive of who
i am as a person not a credential
number five is a vacuum this one is a
bit easier for my husband and i because
we just moved into our first home
and we have laminate flooring so no need
for a vacuum
number six might be surprising to some
of you and it is
my wedding dress our party favors
cards all of that wedding memorabilia
is that the word that you say i don't
really know but a lot of the
times i feel like we keep those things
locked up in an attic boxed up away for
nobody to use
and it's not the physical item
that has brought us joy it is the
closeness and unity in your relationship
as it is for us it didn't really mean
much to us to keep these items because
physical items can never replace the
intangible relationship that we have
number seven is souvenirs a lot of times
we find ourselves collecting these items
at places we visited and this special
stick
which we have no idea where it came from
but we remembered that we kept a special
stick from somewhere
only to just create more waste create
more expense
and we don't really need them number
eight is toaster and mini oven
i find that these bulkier items just
take up a lot more space
and the kitchen that we have now is a
bit small so i didn't want
these large items if i just want to bake
something and just put it in the oven or
my husband loves to build fires outside
so we just
cook outside a lot of the times and as
far as a toaster we just use a griddle
number nine is a dish rack i wanted to
do away with the dish rack because the
kitchen that we have
it again doesn't have a lot of counter
space so we didn't want things just
cluttering up the space i wanted it to
look open
and clean and i'm so fortunate that i
have a large farmhouse sink so i just
wash everything in there hand dry it and
put it away right away
it helps keep my kitchen clean and tidy
most of the time
most number 10 hair curlers
straighteners dryers
all of that equipment for hair i did
away with that about five years ago
because i started to not use them very
often they damaged my hair
and they just made my life more
complicated i don't feel like i really
need to do all that
number 11 i think is hard for a lot of
people and it is nail polish for mani
pedis
i currently don't own any nail polish i
hate the look of chipped nails and i'm
not about to paint my nails
every other day just to prevent that on
the occasion that i do have a special
event to where i need
to look a little bit more presentable as
far as my nails go i just borrow from my
sister borrow from a friend
number 12 is perfume perfume has
something called
endocrine disruptors which have been
linked to cancer
so i definitely opted out for that and i
just use essential oils as far as
smells number 13 is another toxic
and expensive item that i've cut out
from my life and it's lotions
creams body scrubs face washes all that
sort of personal care item
i use cast out soap beeswax balm and
coconut oil and that pretty much takes
care of all of my needs
and it's not toxic to my body number 14
is another on the toxic item list that
i've decluttered
and it is pads and tampons you'd be
surprised if you do your research on
just how harmful they can be
but i now just use a menstrual cup and
cloth pads
number 15 is statement jewelry i
actually now just own just a few pieces
of jewelry that i pretty much wear every
day
and then a few things here and there for
special occasions
number 16 gps i don't think that a lot
of us really need those anymore because
our cell phones already have them built
in
number 17 straws straws are harmful to
the environment well plastic straws are
but i just found that i don't even
really need the reusable straws either
so i just cut them out number 18 another
money saver
is ziploc bags i actually switched to a
silicone bag a couple of years ago and
i've just been using the same silicone
bags
washing them reusing them number 19
dish sponges i switched over to cloth
sponges because they're better for the
environment and i can just reuse them
and re-wash
number 20 pre-made mixes pancake mixes
cake mixes that sort of thing it
actually is pretty easy to make your own
bread and to make your own pancakes
cakes and that sort of stuff if you just
look up some recipes
you'd be surprised 21 clear wrap and
aluminum foil we no longer use these
but i know that as a replacement there
are beeswax
wraps that you can use for food as far
as the clear wrap
i don't know if something else that you
can use for aluminum foil but if you
guys know you can put it in the comments
22 is i think especially important and
it is sentimental items
from previous relationships or
sentimental items that bring back
sad memories you really just have this
one life to live and if something that
you have in your home it's reminding you
of something
sad or is constantly making you feel
guilty
then why do you have it you're meant to
have items in your house that bring you
joy and that bring you happy memories so
just think about those items that you
can possibly declutter from your life
23 is actually something that i've not
had
for several years now and it's social
media i don't feel like i need it and i
feel like the relationships that i have
are actually close
and they're not superficial by any means
24
tea bags i'm actually very fortunate
that my mom is very big into herbs
so i constantly have these natural herbs
that i can use for tea
25 decorative throw pillows
let me know if this is you do you
constantly toss your pillows off the bed
only to put them back in the morning
when you're making the bed
you can just eliminate all that nonsense
26 bottled water we now just use our own
stainless steel cups and a water filter
27 dresser i actually decluttered about
75
of my wardrobe so i didn't really have a
use for it
it was just big and bulky and took up
more space it made my room feel a lot
more cluttered
28 household cleaners and air fresheners
good old baking soda vinegar castou soap
and essential oils
pretty much take care of all your
cleaning needs
29 plastic cups plates and silverware
they're harmful for the environment and
not something that i buy anymore
number 30 is meat i wouldn't necessarily
call ourselves vegan because we do have
chickens and we do eat their eggs
but this is something that we no longer
spend in because it's better for our
health
and it's a lot better for the
environment and our wallet
31 disposable razors we no longer buy
these
if you want to look into that you can
use a safety razor or a rechargeable
electric razor
32 simple cookbooks pinterest does it
all
33 carbonated drinks we actually don't
ever really buy any carbonated drinks
again i have tea we have a water filter
and on the occasion that we want some
juice
i just use my juicer 34
wine glasses and flower vases i find
that good old mason jars do the trick 35
paper calendars i actually love that i
no longer use this i use a google
calendar
because i can share it with my husband i
can share it with my mom who takes care
of my child while i'm working
so i love it for that reason you can
share it with other people and you're
not
creating an extra item in your home
36 might be controversial to some people
but it's baby shoes
and first time really only one time
outfits
let's be real they wear it for like five
minutes and then they either fall off
or they get soiled 37
baby food makers and fancy baby gadgets
i have a whole list of ideas of things
that babies do not
need so if anybody's interested in that
particular list
let me know i could perhaps make a video
on that
38 and this might apply to people with
kids
is battery operated toys i found that a
lot of these items are flashy
they're over stimulating and i think
that they just rob children
of their own creativity 39
promotional t-shirts this one came about
from a documentary that we saw on the
harm
of the fashion industry so if we ever
have a fundraiser where they're asking
us
if we want to pay for a t-shirt we just
donate the money instead if we feel it
in our heart
number 40 manuals you don't really need
to keep a paper copy nowadays because
it's often easy to download them online
41. coffee maker or a kettle
we now just use instant coffee and we
use a pot if we want coffee or tea
42 a bit of a small item but let's be
real we don't need this lemon squeezers
and citrus squeezers
43 this one was painful for me and it
was
unused purses i had a collection of
different
brand name purses that i never used so
now i've limited myself to
one tote bag and one cross bag that's it
44 loofahs luffas you constantly use
you throw them away you get another one
you throw it away they create
so much waste and it's harmful for the
environment so we use a bamboo brush now
instead
45 shaving cream and defilatory creams
shaving cream i just find that soap
works for me i don't know
what you guys try and as far as
defilatory creams they're not very good
for you if you just smell them the
chemicals on them
should warn you 46.
this one was also painful for me and
it's gala style clothing or special
occasion clothing
a lot of the times i think we keep a
special item because
maybe someday i'll wear it or maybe
someday i'll fit into it
maybe someday and it just stays boxed up
stage box stuff
it's taking up space somebody else could
actually be using it
or you could perhaps sell it and make
some money out of it
47 is large unused gym equipment
by no means am i telling you to get rid
of this if you actually use this
and find value in these items but if you
have these items that you're not using
that are just collecting dust
then this is perhaps one way that you
can get a lot of
space in your home and perhaps the money
back
for me i had a treadmill in my house and
i realized
after a few months of having it that i
was going outside and jogging instead
i didn't really need a treadmill 48
tortilla maker this might not be very
applicable to many people
but for my husband and i we are mexican
so we felt that it was fitting we had a
tortilla maker
except through developing some more
health consciousness
we stopped making tortillas so we didn't
really need it anymore
49 is a grill we actually did have a
grill
but it broke and when it did i think it
was great
it couldn't have been better because my
husband started building fires outside
and it started to become more about the
experience of let's go out as a family
let's go find firewood and let's go prep
this fire and let's go
get all the ingredients together it
became more of like a picnic
event so it was great for us
number 50 is very special to me and it's
decorations and knickknacks that we
either
don't believe to be beautiful or to have
a special meaning
we are very intentional about the kinds
of items that we bring into our home
because we feel that home whether it's
an apartment a rental
a house it doesn't matter home should be
like
base when you're playing tag it should
feel like a safe place
open clean and inspiring
so everything that we own either has a
purpose or we find to be beautiful
your idea of what brings inspiration and
beauty is going to be different
but i hope that in any case this gives
you some ideas of things that you can
declutter
so that your space can be more inspiring
and feel more like you
a home free of clutter is the mind free
of clutter
i hope that you love this if you found
any of those tips to be helpful
please give me a like and a thumbs up
and you can comment down below
let me know which of these was the most
helpful for you
thank you bye
you